I'm hi Dave mean academics for hog dog
did you see that clip of him and Drake
drinking on Instagram live I know no
show to me Ryan show it to me
immediately
rying oh my show it to me
let me see this need to see it oh my god
it's so much pain right now from from
what the thing sucks [ __ ] sucks bro
oh here we go here we go here we go here
we go watch this watch this
know that even though let's see it
because I don't know I haven't seen
someone try to impress someone like that
since like high school that was the
funniest [ __ ] to me I know you're
sipping sangria but me personally I'm
sipping an entire cup of Hennessy and
when Drake going let's see it
and his how fast he's like and then his
face after you see that man yo yo Aubrey
you see that red and watery turn he's
not saying anything because he can try
not to gag you know AK you good yeah
and then he goes I want to turn it off
because I don't know what you're gonna
say after that
[Laughter]
because I don't know your about say
after that all right we're gonna link
down respect yo my god yeah I respect I
respect you Drake you're a bad ting no
bro that was him trying to fight in fact
yeah respect oh my god you're my guy you
got a gag so hard he just starts
speaking that way respect bad Monty yeah
bro [ __ ] hell let's see it lets see
I'm a cool man turn it off now you know
after he got taken out of the life he's
sitting there in his room I [ __ ] I'm
gonna just wait yeah for hours hey Daryl
ownage speed wasted dude that [ __ ]
feeling of him holding the cup in the
phone just worth it worth it it's
totally worth it I wonder how often that
happens to rappers like girl like group
he's just trying to pretend like they
can hang yeah it's not even girls it's
like guys like that like it's just
people trying to oh man y'all partying
which rate right now I'm about to go
crazy and they're like oh man you having
somebody's Drake it's like nah man I'm
good I just performed I don't feel too
good he's like I've eaten more from you
knows it I'm crazy let's see it
this never happened to you before where
someone has you've been in a group of
kids and someone's like pass her on a
blunt and you're like yeah yeah oh yeah
what do you mean
yeah I'll do I'll take another one yeah
[ __ ] it I'm Way too high Nam I was
always pretty decent I mean with [ __ ]
with with with post out it wasn't to
that degree but it whenever he's like
you're not gonna drink I definitely felt
pressure to be I got a [ __ ] you know
yeah with the V no who said I what oh
yeah I never doing the matrix bet what
you're not talking to me are you making
the lamest [ __ ] jokes yeah you oh
wait I thought you were talking someone
behind oh port I got a bottle Hennessey
right here you ever heard of Steve we'll
do it check us out this is Noel will do
it more with those [ __ ] lemon drop
shots the first time we hung out that's
when I felt that for the first time in a
while when you think you have to have
any more on my olives holy I have
another that's just like candy I always
want another one
you